- So, what do I call you?
- Just go by Hillary.
- Hillary?
- Yeah.
- Alright, Hillary.
Hillary, where are you from originally?
Where did you grow up?
- I was born in Houston, Texas
but I moved from there
when I was two years old.
And then I basically moved out here
to California and I grew
up in Visalia, Fresno area,
which is about two hours north from here.
- Right.
- And I lived there ever since.
- So you're living in LA now?
- Yes I am.
I just moved from Arizona here.
- Got it.
And tell me about your childhood,
you grew up with both your parents?
- I did not.
So, I actually got taken away from them
when I was two years old,
that's why I had to move from Texas.
And then I went and lived in Nebraska
from two to seven with foster family.
And then thankfully, my
biological grandmother
ended up adopting me when
I was seven years old.
But unfortunately, she
passed away a year later.
So, then I got passed
down to my biological
mother's sister, my aunt and she's
who I call my mother, who raised me
and that is my mother.
And I've been with her ever since.
- What happened to your actual parents?
- They're still, I know that my dad
lives in San Diego apparently.
My mom actually when I go back to Visalia,
I'd see her on the road in
a tent just doing her drugs.
- Oh, really?
(hums in agreement)
- So, she's not doing well, still.
- Yup.
So how was your childhood otherwise?
- Honestly, it was well but
I really don't remember much
from, you know like seventh grade below.
Like, I think a lot of
my brain blocked it out
or something 'cause I don't really
remember much of it.
- Was there any kind of
abuse during your childhood?
Or anything like that?
(chuckles)
- Yeah, one of the reasons I was actually
taken away from my parents
when I was younger,
apparently my mother
had walked in on my dad
molesting me and I was damn nearly
like three years old, so.
- Jesus.
- I don't remember it obviously
'cause I was very young
and as I said previously,
I don't remember a lot
from like seventh grade below.
That was another reason she had like let
like CPS and like know
about that too, so, yeah.
I mean, I don't remember
much, like I was saying
but it's not an easy topic.
- Yeah.
- But, but what I do
remember, it was, it was nice
with the foster family.
- Yeah you had a, you had
some rough (mumbles) there.
(hums in agreement)
What, so you got into
stripping at what age?
- Right when I turned 18.
- 18?
- And I'm 25 now.
- And you worked, that was what city?
- At San Luis Obispo.
So after I turned 18,
I, about two days later,
I got up, moved out of my parents' house
and went to San Luis Obispo.
And I started working
doing outgoing parties
because in San Luis Obispo,
they actually don't have any strip clubs.
Its closest one is like
in Santa, Santa something
and it's still like 30 minutes away.
So I just did outgoing
party like bachelor parties,
birthday parties and all that.
And there's a lot of
work in San Luis Obispo
because a lot of people go there
for like their bachelor parties,
it's very well known for that.
And very expensive town
and fun and all that.
Wine Country, right next to it.
So I just started doing bachelor parties
and all that stuff, and I
still currently do that.
So, but out there's where it started.
- Yeah, and,
what do call it, stripping?
- Exotic dancer, what is? - Yea
- Exotic dancer.
- It's always weird putting
on your application for work
like if you wanna get a real job,
like, what do you?
And I'm like, entertainer?
(laughs)
- So, how do you find that as a career?
Is it, do you get treated
nicely by the guys, your customers?
- Yeah, a lot of 'em are really nice
and then, a lot of 'em
know what you're doing,
know what you want like, we know
this girl's just here
talking to me for the money,
I'm not really what she's
saying I am (chuckles).
But, it's always a hit or miss.
- Yeah.
- And you make good money at it?
(hums in agreement)
- Yeah, pretty decent money.
Like, when I was doing
the bachelor parties,
I was making 19 hour plus tips.
So I'd go home with like
4-500 dollars in an hour,
which is what I like about
doing the outgoing parties
'cause you're always
guaranteed an hourly wage,
or an hourly, whatever you wanna call it.
Rather than at a club, you don't,
you can work for an hour
and not get paid a single dollar.
Like it always depends on who's coming in
like, if you have your
regulars or not and all that.
- What are the downsides
of being an exotic dancer?
- When you wanna get them into like
the VIP rooms and stuff,
as I was mentioning
earlier to you, you gotta sell it.
You gotta tell 'em, "oh
yeah you're gonna get this,
and you're gonna get that,
you can get whatever you want
and then you get back
there and you don't do
any of what you said.
And they get a little pissed
but they already paid out front
so you already made your money (laughs).
But then you just gotta sit there
and hear 'em bitch or let
'em just roll with it.
(chuckles)
- So, do you have kids of your own?
- I do not.
- You don't?
- Actually I have two
boys, my two fur babies.
- Two dogs?
- Yeah.
- Got it.
And so do you find having
relationships tricky
with the career that you have?
- Yeah, some, a lot of people
are judgemental about it.
And then a lot of people,
they praise me for it, they're like,
"wow I can never do that but good for you"
or "good for you."
Relationship wise, like boyfriend?
Yeah, I currently have a boyfriend.
Honestly, the past two
boyfriends I've had,
I've had while I've been dancing
and they've got used to it like,
they're like, "bring
home the money, baby."
(laughs)
But yeah they get jealous,
my first boyfriend
I had doing this he didn't care at all,
he didn't wanna know anything about it,
and my boyfriend now,
he cares a little more,
doesn't really like it
but he wants to like
kind of know like, what goes on, you know?
I don't know, it's just different.
- Yeah.
So, when you were a
kid, did you have dreams
of a different career, different life,
different path for your life?
- Yeah, being an actress actually.
I got accepted to one of the top five
acting schools NYCDA,
New York Conservatory for Dramatic Arts.
But I didn't have the funds to go
right out of high school and that was
the only college that I'd applied for,
but, and I can still go
along that road, I mean,
I'm living in LA, so who knows?
- You never know.
(hums in agreement)
That's great.
What are the worst and best
things about being a dancer?
- The best thing, the
money (laughs) obviously.
- Yup.
- I don't know, I like the attention,
the pole dancing, I like
the pole dancing a lot,
I mean, pole dancing, like just by itself
is the best fitness for you.
And you always like,
you always go into work,
you're gonna find something new everyday.
Like, you're never gonna get bored.
As well with other jobs, if you're like
"oh I gotta go to Subway
and make some sandwiches today, you know?"
Like, you're always gonna have fun
and find something, maybe find a person
with more money than last night, you know?
(laughs)
- Any downsides to it?
- Yeah, a lot.
Lot of guys try and, when
you get back into the rooms,
they try and take advantage of you
and like, I've gotten guys
kicked out of there before
like, and then, yeah,
there's a lot of just really rude
people too like, there's
been times where like
girls would just come into the club
and just be there by themselves actually,
just like a group of them,
they just sit there and just talk down.
Another side, another times,
there'll be a bunch of
girls that will come in
and just love getting lap dances from you.
So, yeah, there can be a lot of hate
towards it, just like every
other industry too though.
- Yeah.
- But yeah,
I don't know, I don't, I don't know.
I personally like it, I mean,
I'm still doing it, I'm 25,
I've been doing it for seven years now
but you just gotta let,
when people just talk
shit upon you or, you just
gotta let that pass you by
and be like, "well,
whatever," like, I don't know.
- You've gotta have a thick skin.
- Yeah, you have to have,
I was just about to say,
you have to have thick skin and not let
what other people say get to you.
Just work for your money.
(chuckles)
- Alright Hillary, thank you so much
for coming in and talking to me
and,
- Yeah.
- Good luck with wherever
you go from here.
- Thank you.
- Thanks.